[Music]
and fourth i'm voting really
you don't look like him which actor was
almost completely nude on set
since their costume was created by cgi
today we're taking a look at some of the
most shocking and impressive costumes
that were created with cgi magic
which marvel suits had to be added with
digital effects
why did every frame of black panther in
captain america civil war have to be
edited in post
i'm hella kate blanchett's hella is
amazingly fierce
but the actress didn't really feel that
way while she was filming
the costume is a major contributor but
blanchett was performing without any of
it since the majority of the inspired
outfit was actually added in
post-production
to make it even worse blanchett was
wearing the awkward mocap suit while
filming in australia
to say things got a bit too warm is an
understatement
luckily she did benefit from having a
much easier time getting herself to the
washroom than her co-stars
i am not my father one of the most
impressive full cgi suits we've seen on
screen is definitely chadwick boseman's
black panther
bozeman was performing on set in almost
the exact same costume
but while the team was editing they
replaced the suit digitally in nearly
every frame it might seem a bit
pointless considering bozeman looked so
similar in reality but there was one
small yet brilliant detail that just
couldn't be caught by the camera
and that is the shimmer and texture we
see on the vibranium mesh parts of the
costume
six stones three teams
one shot all the time suits we see in
avengers end war were courtesy of
cgi and a tight schedule the costume
designers had their work cut out for
them and with such a tight shooting
schedule
they started needing to make major
decisions and quickly
the suits which are a combo of ant-man
tony stark and the guardians technology
wound up needing to be rendered
digitally since they didn't have the
time to actually make and fit the
costumes properly
by the end of the process they did have
physical models of the costume
but what we see in the movie is all cgi
the sun is setting and the magic horizon
while on screen delevine looks
fantastical in her enchantress costume
and suicide squad
but there was a lot less magic to look
at behind the scenes
de levine was actually a nude underwear
while filming
with full body makeup but the actual
clothing
helmet included was all computer
generated in post-production
it was an interesting choice to have so
much skin showing under the cgi clothing
that really adds to the mysticism of it
all
not really who you think i am brie
larson's suit in captain marvel
was actually designed for avengers end
game
since she shot her scenes for end game
before she did the captain marvel movie
the designers decided they wanted to use
the suit from end game as the
original captain marvel suit they wound
up having to digitally add the new suit
over top the original getup for that
movie this
is definitely part of the risk when
filming things out of sequence
we were pretty surprised to learn that
tom holland was sporting a digitally
rendered suit as spider-man and captain
america civil war
holland was meant to wear the actual
superhero suit but since he only
appeared in the special threads in the
airport showdown
the majority of the frames were going to
be computer generated anyhow
one of the most impressive parts was
definitely the eyes and the way they
managed to give the goggle-like look of
the original comics
as for when holland is burying the iron
spider-man armor
that's entirely cgi behind the scenes he
was wearing a motion capture suit to
film in
all those breakthroughs military funding
honey
iron man started wearing semi-cgi suits
back in 2008.
robert downey jr did have some practical
gear on to support him in his
performance
but ultimately in post-production
digital editing took over for some
scenes
and the suit was actually superimposed
over the actor's body
the editors had modeled the suit we
often see on screen
after the actual suit downey jr was
wearing which helped keep the look in
sync throughout the movie
the looks have changed over the years
but his very first suit
was definitely impressive when it came
out
have you concluded admiring yourself
yeah ryan reynolds glowing skin-tight
suit isn't real at all
this getup was completely computer
generated and to be honest
it kind of shows while the idea behind
the costume was neat
unfortunately it didn't totally work out
the way the team had hoped
this was mainly because of tight
deadlines and the rush of getting the
film to the screen
the idea behind it was that the power
would come from within the character and
beam out but
ultimately it didn't totally translate
have eyes on loki 14th floor i'm not
loki
when it came to the cap vs cat battle
audiences were very confused as to which
cap was which at first
since both characters and actors looked
extremely similar
otherwise so in post-production the team
decided the solution was to add a helmet
which of course had to be added
digitally with cgi
come while the final product in the film
was cgi magic
each of the navi costumes was actually
physically made
the outfits themselves were pretty
simple but a particular focus was put on
the textures and fabrics being used
since the animators needed to have
examples as references for when they
took over and digitally rendered
the looks for the actors saldana was
instead on set wearing a
highly complex cgi suit with all sorts
of tracking and recording tools to help
bring all her motions to the screen
i cannot be summoned like the mongrel
this entirely digitally created costume
was so good
it was worthy of an oscar behind the
scenes
jones was actually wearing a motion
capture suit his entire costume was
digitally rendered and applied for the
final cut of the movie
the outside world has no place for
creature like me
instead of a giant beast suit the beast
actor dan stevens was actually wearing
an
enormously padded motion capture suit
and had to wear platform shoes to get
him to the height he needed to be
behind the scenes it looked pretty
awkward but
stevens manages to let his performance
shine through emma watson has her work
cut out for her as well
acting as if she were face to face with
this creature as opposed to a large gray
blob that stevens really was
the costumes the beast wears are pretty
magical and
highly detailed and not a day goes by
where it doesn't haunt me
michael shannon was not a fan of the
motion capture suit he had to wear
behind the scenes of man of steel
he even said it made him feel like a
court jester
he'd originally asked schneider to
promise he wouldn't have to wear it but
ultimately they had to for the sake of
bringing the best cgi to life
it was necessary to make it appear like
the armor he wears was fitted to his
body
and of course following the natural
motions
four or five moments that's all it takes
colossus was a major collaborative
effort for the team behind deadpool
it took five performers alone to bring
the giant metallic covered character to
the screen
a motion capture session was done with
one performer
a different six foot nine actor wearing
platform heels
shot a bunch of scenes on set in a
motion capture tracking suit
the face was modeled after a different
performer while another provided the
voice of colossus
and then the actual face movements were
performed by yet another person
rebel wilson along with the rest of the
incredible cast from the movie cats
including dame judi dench and jason
derulo
had completely digitally created
costumes
well really fur the actors still wore
skin tight green motion capture suits
but their fur and other cat details were
added by the cgi team
no part of the actor is actually seen
since their bodies were digitally edited
anyhow
we were really surprised to see just how
many costumes turned out to be fully cgi
especially the suits like black panther
that just had small and subtle bits
added
the detail in all of them is behind
impressive
especially those with a lot of fur which
cgi costume surprised you the most